ob diese erfindung hätte meine kindheit
wirklich viel angenehmer gemacht nie
wieder bohren wissenschaftler durch den
tal institutes pink kommt es in london
dabei für eines der unangenehmsten
geräusche und zahnärztlichen tüchtigen
abhilfe zu schaffen es geht um ein
geräusch das vielen leuten sehr
unangenehm ist unter fink vor geräusch
eines winkel stück besser bekannt als
fan ab bohrer das geräusch das in einer
zahnarztpraxis hat immer schon aus dem
wartezimmer aus wahrgenommen werden kann
und manchmal auch begleitet vom schreien
da für viele leute ein unangenehmer
drohen da häufig auch eben mit dem
schmerz beim bohren assoziiert wird
problematisch denn gebohrt werden muss
eigentlich immer wenn in den fächer
klassen ein artikel in den feind ipic
report berichtet jetzt aber über eine
angenehme entwicklung im bereich der
zahnmedizin mit hilfe von biologisch
abbaubaren und mit thiede group ein aus
der alzheimerforschung bekanntes mittel
versehenen kollagen schwämmen kriegten
die forscher bei mäusen den stammzellen
aufbau der zähne an das ergebnis ist
sensationell nach dem einsatz des
schwammes regenerierten sich die zähne
so lange bis sich der schwamm inklusive
katalysator selbst aufgelöst hatte der
zellwachstum war also voll und ganz
kontrollierbar wie professor von short
vom king's college london selbst
berichtet sei die einfachheit dieser
behandlung perfekt für klinische zwecke
ob und wenn ja und wann die ersten
studien mit menschen durchgeführt werden
das ist noch nicht bekannt ja aber
vollkommen schmerzfrei und eigentlich
einfach kann übrigens auch der handel
mit aktien sein
seht euch die infos dazu bei volkswagen
financial services an dafür hier klicken
wo ich mit denise die wichtigsten fragen
für dem thema durch gehe aber zurück zur
zahnbehandlung würdet ihr eine solche
behandlung einer herkömmlichen vorfinden
also ich auf jeden fall was mir euer
feedback in den kommentaren da einen
daumen hoch ein kostenloses abo dafür
hier klicken und bis dann